hi so this is my last day in
south america
uh steve kaufman here of course
and uh i'm in miraflores which is a very
lovely part of lima
and i'm gonna be putting up some videos
from downtown lima from the main square
from chinatown
i'm going to show you some
scenes from miraflores the people
exercising exercising in the streets on
a sunday
peru
again every country i've been in has
been a discovery because i know much
about these countries
and of course opportunities to speak
spanish and portuguese now i'm heading
back to north america to palm springs
where i'm going to spend a month
in the sun
and get back to learning my arabic
but it's been a wonderful wonderful
discovery
and uh really enjoyed it
so
uh
i hope you enjoy these videos bye
all right here we are in the plata de
armas in lima the main square
this was the center of the spanish
administration for whatever 300 years
they ruled
south america central america from here
but i want to talk about spanish
learning
and
because i've said before you know i very
much focus on input-based learning to
get my vocabulary up
my comprehension up but at the end you
have to speak you have to speak a lot
and the best language teachers are the
taxi drivers so we just took a taxi from
our hotel in miraflores to the square
here it was about a half hour taxi ride
it cost on uber six solids which is
roughly two us dollars and the whole
time i'm talking the taxi driver he's
telling me about education in brazil
how president fujimori fukimori even
though he's corrupt he created a lot of
colleges education is on the up and up
people are better educated
and it is interesting that in peru you
have a sense of optimism which i didn't
get in argentina and brazil where people
are more depressed about their
chances the corruption the
education the insecurity here people
seem a little more optimistic at least
that was my very superficial impression
but the big thing is i had a 30 minute
spanish conversation
for two us dollars plus we gave him
about a 25
tip because he felt sorry for him
driving all that way and spending all
that gas and only getting the equivalent
of two us dollars
was the same in brazil the taxi drivers
are so enthusiastic they love to talk it
was the best portuguese teacher i could
have had and it was the same in
argentina in buenos aires so of course
the trick is
it's not that cheap to fly here but once
you get here because the taxis are
relatively inexpensive
uh it's a great way to practice speaking
i mean i could spend the whole day
riding around in taxis or uber cars and
speaking spanish or portuguese in brazil
however for that to work you have to get
your level up and i always say work on
getting your comprehension comprehension
your vocabulary up then you can go to
the country and you can take advantage
of
casual strangers or
taxi drivers in countries where they are
very very reasonable so
that's what i wanted to say the best
teachers in many of these countries and
i should say too that i have kind of
ignored latin america never spent any
time here i didn't pay much attention i
was learning my slavic languages my
greek now my arabic actually latin
america is a phenomenal continent they
have good food they have different
countries with different history they
have
history from before
the discovery or
not discovery the conquest or in
the invasion by the europeans there's
lots here and i think a lot of potential
and maybe peru is optimistic and
colombia wasn't there as optimistic and
maybe brazil and argentina will become
optimistic and chill he's doing well
lots of potential i'm glad i came
and i'll continue on my way back to the
hotel speaking spanish with my taxi
driver bye for now
here we are
and this is
our restaurant
the one we're going into
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you